Gnosticism is the general banner under
which all of this stuff can be placed
Gnostics believe the central tenant of
Gnosticism and it's hard to put this
across because modern Gnostics are such
cheerful people but they they've
forgotten their their real roots the the
central perception of Gnosticism no
matter how you slice it is that we don't
belong here that we are strangers that
something terrible happened and that
accounts for why we're here that we were
destined for a much better deal and
something went terribly terribly wrong
it takes different forms as some Gnostic
mythology's are fairly straightforward
summer that fairly baroque the one that
I enjoy is one of the more baroque ones
the second century gnostic bishop
valentin iasts had this notion that
there were 36 archons
they are demons of progressively
lessening power that interposed
themselves between man and a true vision
of God and the last of the archons the
36th Archon was Sophia and the only of
the archons that was female there's a
tremendous sexual ambivalence in
Gnosticism which we can talk about which
is resolved in different ways but anyway
the 36th Archon is Sophia
she looked upward toward the higher God
and saw him bring forth creation of
which she was the final manifestation
and in her heart an avarice grew a wish
to create in the same manner as the
highest and hidden all-father and she
brought forth it's described as an
abortion she self fertilized herself she
did not understand the requisites of
creation and she turned inward into
herself and she brought forth a
monstrosity and this monstrosity is the
god of the old testament yahwah
Jehovah and when she saw what she had
done that she had brought forth this
monstrosity she flashed through a whole
bunch of emotions very quickly horror
guilt rage fear agony like that and
these emotions of the errant Sophia
condensed as the material world over
which hildog woth was then made
so the entire material universe is seen
as the condensed emotional debris of the
horror of the 36th Arcon upon witnessing
her own creation who has then made God
over this universe well even though this
is this really bad scene it's still
nevertheless has this extremely tenuous
connection to the highest and hidden
all-father in the form of what is called
the scintilla spark the soul spark of
divinity so then the goal of Gnostics
born into this unfortunate world is to
gather the light together to save the
light the light is defiled by its
presence in the world of material
existence and the light must be gathered
will so then the central soteriological
concern that means the central salvation
or concern of Gnosticism is how shall we
gather the light and their whole
theology then is what is the light how
should we gather it and once we have it
what do we do with it
and then there were various answers
[Music]
you